for every 16 point increase in a woman's
iq her prospect of marriage decreases by
40 percent what do you do about that i
don't think there's anything you can do
about it i do feel for young girls you
have ambitions and you want to be
something you want to achieve all these
things and make quite a bit of money
good for you you should aim for that
sort of thing but it comes with the
consequence of knowing that men that you
are looking to get with in a long-term
relationship aren't interested in those
things competence in many domains is not
something which is seen as attractive by
the sex that you're trying to attract as
a woman and on top of that they use up
the single most important resource and
the most attractive quality you have
which is time you spend your 20s getting
educated building up your career and
earning money to find out that men don't
care about your education level your
career or your wealth and now you're
older than some women who you're now
trying to compete with it's not kicking
the balls that's a punch of the tits
it's a punch in the tit you're correct